capture the pawn queen take the pawn and
the white king is about to go running
yeah first however levon aronian flicks
in a check this knight is poisoned black
cannot capture this knight with his rook
because then white's f7 pawn white's
pawn far advanced pawn would become a
new queen and that would actually end up
in checkmate so black's king had to run
away from this check it's hitting uh
hitting he's hidden in the corner now
he's hiding in the corner and now this
checkmate threat's still on the board
magnus carlsen though gesturing there he
missed this move ivanka called it the
white king has an escape route and no
more checkmate magnus carlson he's
grabbed a rook back but it looks like it
should be game over why can even maybe
just make a new queen now yeah that's
what i'm looking at promote the pawn and
then the king can still run away when
the queen comes to check him
yeah there we go it's
a third queen on the board magnus carson
resigns wow
oh okay defeat for the norwegian
after a difficult day yesterday